Eight walkers at the, but, well, I don't
understand how you think that we, we,
you're almost losing America and there's
a battle for America in every regard in
terms of just the people that
were running like Hillary Clinton.
Like this woman was a globalist.
Like, just think about who we were,
who we were in bed with, like Saudi Arabia
selling all of our uranium to Russia.
Like, like Trump came in and was like,
no, like America people. We were the gap.
Like we lost them.
We're losing the middleclass a gap
between the rich and the poor was like
literally causing that, uh, policies,
shipping all of our jobs overseas,
the regulation,
the government getting bigger and better.
You can't do anything as an entrepreneur
entrepreneur in America without a piece
of paper from the government, discouraging
people with this piece of paper,
like sending,
like shutting down the factories from
getting that there's something, you know,
there's a little land between New York and
La, I believe it or not. Like, you know,
and this is what Trump understood.
We were losing that and,
and Trump appealed to that.
Those people. I'm still floored,
like as I'm traveling the world and
seeing different pieces of the country,
I'm learning how ignorant I was like,
and that's the best thing
in the entire world.
Just I fell victim to the idea that
like it was progress, it was progress,
it was progress. We have to care about
the environment. It was progress.
And it's like,
no,
like we've been losing America has been
losing and Donald Trump understood that.
And in a way that I didn't end, I thought
we have to care about the environment.
Not even a little bit, not
even a little bit. No. Okay.
Let me, let me clarify this.
I don't throw trash on the ground. Like,
and I'm not saying like we need to like,
you know, trash the environment. Like, um,
but do I believe in climate change? No.
You don't believe in climate change?
I think the climate always changes,
I guess is what I should do.
I believe that this is like,
you know, an issue that,
um, is being that that
is fatal global warming,
which they've changed conveniently.
They got rid of the word one.
Scientists started disproving it now
based only say client climate change. Um,
now I think that that was just a way
to extract dollars from Americans.
I don't at all believe they had no
actionable plan. It was great for Trump.
Took out of that deal.
It was terrible. Okay.
But this is an incredibly
complicated subject, right?
If you would have to talk to a bunch of
different scientists and see how they
gathered data and see what they understand
about co two levels and what's the
danger of them, right, and what
can combat it and what could not.
Have you done all this? So I think
flipping opinion. Listen, I'm not,
this is not, this wouldn't
be the hill I died on, right?
But it's not about the part. I just
genuinely, I've read a ton about it,
but I would not be able to, I would not
be able to come to you and say like,
this is my strong opinion. But here's
like the easiest way to say this, right?
The fact that there is a disparity in the
science committee about whether or not
it's real, it's enough to have
very little disparity. Most, most,
most scientists,
most the vast majority agree that human
beings are negatively affecting climate
change. Yeah. The vast
majority. Yeah. I don't,
I just don't think so.
So you think that the very few scientists
that disagree with the consensus or
the ones that are correct? Well,
I think if something is it, it's,
it's either subjective or it's objective
and their objective truths. Right.
But it's subjective.
If you're saying that there are some,
I don't think there's very little,
there are some that don't get paid to go
on TV then some of that or not bill Nye
who are not funded scientists.
Um, and, and that has been a hold,
well not assigned to,
you know,
just not broke my heart
when I found out mouthpiece.
But that's the, that's the
point. The son of a good word.
I don't think Al Gore is a scientist,
but bill Nye is like a science
influencer or a science entertainer.
Like it doesn't have a background in
actual science. He's not a scientist,
doesn't have a phd in science,
had to do with Phil Knight.
He promotes science.
Science is not bad.
But the real problem is with climate
change is that we for sure there has been
ups and downs throughout the history
of this planet. There are observable.
They've,
they followed them and we was one of the
subjects that I had earlier today with
um, Dr Robert Schoch in
2014, the vast majority,
87% of scientists said that human
activity is driving global warming.
Yet only half the American public
public ascribe to that view.
So 87% and this is scientific
American dotcom though.
Like that, that means it's, it's
making money. I don't trust that.
If it was a.org I would
probably take that.
But that this is just a random
website and scientific American is not
necessarily a random website. I don't
believe this at all. Just so you know,
you don't believe it. Like I genuinely
don't believe it. I know you do,
but I genuinely don't believe it.
I believe most of the time the consensus
of scientists that are studying the
data,
and so what they're doing is studying all
of the stories that came out about the
scientists that said that when they tried
to present their evidence to show like
they were basically just getting
shut down at every corner.
You can pull that up too. Like scientists
who look up, look up the opposite, right.
Instead of instead of looking for,
didn't search for it.
That's what I've found when
I searched it. Sorry. Yeah.
Look up is my question. Why are
you so sure? This is an extremely,
extremely complicated subject.
I said,
I am not so sure that I would die on
the hill for it. My opinion right now,
and it's just that it was a means,
because forget the fact of whether
you believe global warming is real.
Let's say it's 100% real estate. We know
faculty wheel. Is there a, well, let's,
let's be clear. Global warming, global
climate change is definitely real.
It's happening. The question is, has
happened. Yes. It has always happened.
What are we, what is the, this is the
climate change. Yes, the climate changes.
It was different weather
yesterday than it was today.
The climate is forever changing like that.
That's the problem is that
people are making it seem
like that's something weird.
No, not less. Not your, you're
misrepresenting the issue.
The issue is people think that human
beings are exacerbating climate change to
the point where there's a,
there's a tipping point.
We cross over that tipping point.
We're going to deal with huge problems
that could be corrected if we act now and
put a lot of funding into climate control
and this is what Howard bloom was on
talking about a few days ago.
He was talking about that the real
future involves the technology of climate
control and that what we have to be really
careful of is letting it get too far
where you can't ever
stop it and pull it back.
This is what scientists are warning about.
This is why they want emission standards.
This is why they want to figure out how
to get people to be aware of the fact
that this is a real issue. Now
it regardless. Human beings,
if they never existed, the earth
has constantly gone through cycles.
The question is not whether or not the
earth has gone through cycles of cooling
and warming, right? The question
is, are we exacerbating that?
The vast majority of scientists
say we are okay now this could,
this could negatively impact
all sorts of coastal cities.
This could be a gigantic problem.
This is not like propaganda that's drummed
up by some sort of big business that
seeks to make money off
of this or some sort of a,
well, they won't even say ship it.
Al Gore might've made some money off,
but who's making money off we went that
we were in and they were, they were.
That was like the amount of
money that America was losing.
But here's what I was gonna ask you,
so let's just let mount of money.
America was losing. What do you, who
was the mayor of Paris Agreement?
This is the reason why we wanted to
get out of the Paris agreement is,
but that's where I wanted to get to.
Let's say we all agree that global warming
is real. I don't believe it's real.
Okay. So I can't sit here. The
question for why have a belief?
What do you mean?
Why have a belief as to whether or not
global warming is real or not real?
Because I just, I just find that
you don't understand the science,
but why have a belief in it? Right. So
it's how I believe it's on a belief in,
I don't believe in it. But you have a
belief that it doesn't exist. I know.
I personally think that
this was just the next,
the fact that it was presented to us
by Al Gore and it's just, it was, yeah.
Not presented to us by just by Al
Gore. Al Gore made a v a film. Right.
And he's been called like the first green
billionaire who's made a shit load of
yeah.
Any flies in his private plane because
he's so worried about the admissions.
Okay. That is hilarious.
Hilarious about that.
All of the people that are telling
us a fucking politician, right.
There's gross and is to all that stuff.
Right. And that's what worries me.
So my question is, let's
say that it's real. Okay.
Let's just assume like if that's
the best way to have it today,
let's say it's 100%.
Yeah.
Do you feel that you have found in your
research that there is something that
human beings can do that
would change this all around?
That's possible?
Yes.
One of the things that they're figuring
out how to pull carbon out of the
atmosphere and even even
possibly reuse it. There's,
there's all sorts of things that people
are trying to do. I mean we had, um,
what was the young man who made
that uh, device boy, boy on slot.
He figured out a way to uh,
make this device that pulls plastic out
of the oceans. They're figuring out a way
very important.
Yeah.
There's a lot of it will pick as
plastic just can't like over time.
But that's what I mean. Like,
so when I say that I'm like,
and I believe in recycling.
Like I'm not like a person that's like,
this is the idea that the government is
just going to take the trillions dollars
because we're in some agreement where
we're all agreeing that we should do
something. Is, is useless.
And look from the stuff.
Like there's obviously a lot of debate
here. And as I said, like I'm not,
so at the one thing you'll always find
with me is I'll never pretend to be so
educated.
Something like I'm not going out in
college campuses talking about global
warming. I don't do that. Right. But why
are you saying that you don't, I just,
I just don't, I just, I don't know.
Maybe because they got so close,
maybe because it got so politicized,
uh, studies into scientific
agreement on human cause,
global warming and look
at all the studies.
It's between a hundred
percent and 91% at the lowest.
91% of one of the studies from 2014
with the Union of concerned scientists.
Yeah. Work. They almost, it's,
it's a pretty broad consensus.
Who Do,
who are they pulling?
Is it the people that are a part of
this? No. Um, it's a good question.
That's what I'm asking.
10,306 scientists to confirm.
Over 97% of climate scientists agree in
over 97% of the scientific articles find
that global warming is real
and largely caused by humans.
So my question to you is if you want to
step outside of the scientific consensus,
which is vast and involves
10,306 scientists and just say,
I don't believe in it. Yeah, even if
you're right, even if you're right,
you don't have enough information
to say that. Right? Correct.
I said this is what you're saying.
You don't.
I don't,
but yeah,
I would have to have someone sit down
and convince me that it was real.
I personally don't believe
it. That's okay. It's good.
It's good to start at a place of not
believing something. No, it's not.
You think you should start with
believing everything. Okay.
It's did not believe either or
not believe. Yes. Not believe, no,
but don't say you don't
believe. Yeah. I learn about it.
Learn about it and then have an opinion.
But you're stating this
opinion without having any real
standing on what climate science, but
that's, that's exactly what an opinion is.
I'm not going, like I said,
if, if, if you said that Ken,
as you went on to 10,000 college
campuses and you said that global warming
wasn't real, then we'd have a problem.
You and I are just having a conversation.
Yeah. But why have an opinion on
something that you don't have data about?
This is my question. Like, yeah,
I don't necessarily have an opinion
on climate science. I really don't,
cause I don't know much about it.
But what I do know is that what I've
read is that the vast majority of people
study it or an agreement the
human beings are affecting. Yeah.
I don't, I just, my recall on a
lot of the things that I read,
and this was a while ago, so this is why
where I, when I first formed my opinion,
I'm not believing this. I read a shit
ton of articles, can't recall the data.
Cause it's like I said, this was
something I was super passionate about.
It was like somebody posted something
and then I went on like a tear or reading
about it. Um, but it was
essentially just noting that.
And a lot of the studies,
like when you go in, you,
if we had time to sit down and really
pull this up, they're pulling, you know,
10,000 scientists that are within a
community that is fun. Like these.works.
Do you believe? And everything that
media matters. Dot media matters.
Dot Org puts out for statistics.
Right? That's a political,
that's a arm of the Democratic Party,
but I know,
but I'm just politics versus science,
but this has been politicized that
science has been politicized. Yes, it has.
Global warming in particular has been
politicized 100% it has been politicized.
Right.
That's the whole reason that I fell down
this dark hole one night reading about
it and I did. I was like, you know
what mean the day? I don't really care.
It has been politicized.
I think that's also maybe why you're
saying you don't agree with it so quickly
because it's an idea.
That's why I read it.
An ideological right wing point
is that global warming isn't real.
If you're one of those people that
thinks global warming isn't real,
you're almost always on
the right and that's fine.
But I'm telling you that again,
I didn't do a deep dive on all of this
because I read about it because it was at
a forefront of discussion.
And so I read about it all night and my
conclusion was that they started pulling
up all of these studies from the person
that you know did this and I did a deep
dive on and they started showing how like
these community of scientists were in
fact somewhere behind that.org as
someone that was being funded. So to me,
the issue got to politicize for me to,
to,
to believe that global warming was
something that was going to wipe out the
world.
Now that is a fact,
but that doesn't mean that the funding
affects the scientific research and the
data which they all agree on.
And this is universally
across the entire plant,
thousands and thousands of scientists
would not stake their reputation on false
data.
What what they're saying is not that
the only reason why the world is getting
warm is because human beings that the
only reason why the climate isn't totally
static for the rest of eternity
because of human beings.
What they're saying is we are negatively
impacting our own environment and we're
doing it because we existing negative in
RG and we use coal and fossil fuels and
emissions and we're raising our co two
levels and this is based on data and this
is,
this is something that you can look at.
You could look at the data and follow
where they're getting this information
from and follow how they're making
these conclusions and follow.
The vast majority of these brilliant
people study the shit their whole life.
And if I look,
if I was a person that was putting forth
policy on climate change or if I was a
person that put out by opinion
publicly on Paul on on climate change,
I would do all of that. I'm just
not, I understand what you're saying,
but what I'm saying is that you are a
very smart person and people listen to you
and they're going to listen to you for
a long time. I believe this is a this,
but hold on, let me finish
what I'm saying. One,
depending on how you don't have to
have a formal opinion on everything.
What you do have to have is the ability
to know when you don't know what the
fuck you're talking about. You said
you don't believe it. Don't be.
Maybe you asked me and I said this
wouldn't be the hill I chose to die on
because I don't,
I don't why?
Let's say you don't believe
in because I just personally,
if you bought not have a belief until
you really prefer if my language as
opposed to admitting that I do not
know this, I wouldn't die on this hill.
I've never made a B.
I've never made a public statement.
You would have preferred if I had
just started it by saying I have no,
I have no opinion. No, don't know.
Okay. That's what I'm saying. You, you
say, don't you say, I don't believe in it.
I don't believe it.
You're,
you're saying really clearly that
you don't think it's real. I mean,
I think it would be the same if I
said to you like, you know, uh, do,
do you believe in God right
now? I would say, I don't know.
I feel like this is sort of
like linguistics though. No,
I would say, I don't know.
I always say I'm agnostic. People say
like, I believe I believe it or I don't.
Right. So it's like if you say, I think
a lot of people say they don't know.
I think believe is definitely where
the associated with God. But, um,
but if you say, I don't believe in God,
and then somebody starts saying, oh,
you need to form it did, it's like, it
just, I just don't believe in it. No,
you don't.
Because God is not scientific data.
There's a big difference between measuring
the co two levels in the atmosphere
and the deciding whether or not
there's an afterlife. I just, I,
I'm sorry that I just don't believe,
I don't believe in global warming.
I'm happy to
five.
I had married an influencer and
you're a very bright person.
I would if somebody had asked me like
at a place where on influencing on a
college campus, what's your
opinion? I would say I have none.
I bet you would say I don't
believe in it like you just did.
Absolutely not what you just did it.
There are so many instances where
you could watch it just like,
and you can ask Dave Ruben when he asks
me a question, I say I don't have, no,
you and I are having a
conversation one on one. I'm not,
I'm not sitting here to try to,
I don't go on campus talking about
global warming because I don't,
I don't have an opinion on it. If you
press me and asked if I believe in it. No,
I don't really believe in it,
but it could I go deep dive and and,
and learn that perhaps I'm wrong.
Sure.
I personally am inclined to believe that
a lot of those studies are manipulated.
As I said during the one night that did
deep dive on it and when they showed
like all of the pieces
of evidence or whatever,
it just seemed a little shaky and
I felt that it was politicized.
But I think I have a right to say
that I don't believe in something,
but I then I also don't know.
And that's what I said to you.
I don't believe in it,
but I wouldn't die on this hill.
I don't know enough about it.
But you also said you don't believe
in it and you stated the reason why,
because you think it's a scam. I don't,
that's the truth. What do want me to do?
I'm gonna lie to you. I'm not, I'm not
sitting here saying like hated issue.
It may complicate. That's fine. But what
do you want me to lie to you and say,
if I'm not a politician, you want me to
say you should the correct term. Like the,
I feel like this is like the editing of
people do like when they're like, oh,
a bond. If they ask a
question, you don't know.
This is the way I'm not running for
office. I'm answering, I'm talking to you.
I don't believe in it. I
appreciate you. I can't be fake.
This is my number one problem
in life is I can't be fake.
And I know that you're pressing the air
and that you want me to adjust and to
say like, I don't, I do not have an
opinion or the, but I'm not a politician.
I'm telling you I don't believe in it.
Could I? Could I change my perspective?
It was even in a year after I read
just a regular person, you said,
I don't believe that I'd probably go all
right. The problem is you're not, you're,
you're, uh, you're a very influential, I'm
aware when I'm on stage, when I'm on my,
you could tell you
there's no videos of can.
If someone's talking about global
warming, I'm aware of that. Exactly.
Now it's going to be rubbing again. It's
by the way. I should, yeah, exactly.
We're going to be mad at me.
We know. What's funny though,
is that like it, this feels so like
we're not on the Internet right now,
but it's like I still don't
feel like we're on the
Internet. This is the problem.
Yeah. Well, like if we were,
if you and I are on a college
campus, I'd be like, Eh, I,
I'm not really sure.
I don't have them for my discussion.
Jack Shit about global
warming or really don't. Yeah.
I think with the real fear
is not even global warming.
The real fear is global cooling.
The Ice Age is the most terrifying thing
that can happen. Human beings. Yeah.
That shit happens. Everybody dies.
Yeah. I know. Global warming,
you just move inland.
Yeah.
I think that the real thing that
people are concerned about is like,
just beyond any of that stuff.
I don't know.
I think that there's like
more concerned in society.
Like I personally think
that some scientists are
talking about global warming
and it got politicized.
They figured it was another way to extract
human beings money because of fear.
That's my opinion. Okay. I think
there's probably some truth to that.
We're going to find our core scientists
that agree with everything we saved.
It's improving that Harvard studies
had been in incorrect because they were
being funded by, I'm certain you
know, political interest groups,
so I'm not inclined to pull
up something on a, and. M
I'm blanking.
It'll come back to me in a second.
But there were Harvard papers that had
been funded by certain researchers that
are trying to get a certain political
position out in it causes mass fear and
people are willing to spend their money
a certain way. Charlie possible. It is.
It's real. That's very real. People
are flawed, so I'm not inclined.
When someone pulls up an article
and says, look, a 10,000 scientists,
I err on the side of, okay, I
don't know those scientists are,
I don't know what the rest
organization is funded by,
so I'm going to stick by my guns and say,
I don't really believe in it yet. Now,
if I decide that I'm going to run for
office and I've got to make a decision on,
on the atmosphere and in,
in what we're going to do about
global warming and cu two missions,
you better believe I will be
fully ready to discuss it.
I'm not going to make a youtube video
and just know the outskirts of it.
I don't do that. Right. But if you
and I are having a discussion, sorry,
I don't believe it. Like, I mean
almost to say, open, open to learning,
open to learn, always open to
learning. I've, I've been wrong before.
I was a liberal two years ago, you
know, um, or three years ago. So that's,
that's not a problem. I'm
open to learning, but I'm not
going to like pretend like,
say something that feels inauthentic.
And what I wanted to say there was,
I don't believe in it. It's just one
of those things that it's become,
it's a real right wing talking points.